i love failure i fail every day i don't
care about it just get on with it
a prayer so now you've got itsu you are
absolutely an entrepreneur at heart as
all the fish are going in one way you
suddenly look around you think damn it
i'm going to go the other way when you
look back at pran at business you ended
up selling for 2 billion i had no idea
what i was doing it wasn't planned
endless moments of magic moments of
bizarre creativity and confidence what
was motivating you i wanted to make a
difference i suddenly found myself with
this responsibility to open a restaurant
from that start we built
76 of them we started developing it so
it could become the future
the absence of both parents he was quite
distant my father my mother committed
suicide when i was seven that created a
loneliness
to create something new you've got to
put yourself in slightly uncharted
territory business isn't just business
to you is it it's not just about the
money no and it shouldn't be to anyone
i'm far more interested in the
relationships with the customer and the
staff and the product i was obsessed by
that obsessed it's incredible what
people can do people don't trust them
people don't nurture them because
they're too busy being selfish nurturing
themselves
what's the worst crisis you've ever had
in your business i don't even want to go
into it i want to hear it
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
julian yeah
i was exposed to a number of hardships
as a child
you said that
what did you mean
i love the way you start off with a real
killer
i can't remember who i said that to
um
and
i was expecting well i'm not i'm not
alone by the way a great many people
watching this or listening to this were
exposed to hardships far greater than
mine but the death of my mother when i
was seven she my mother committed
suicide on boxing day
uh so i was left and my parents were
divorced
so we we lived uh the three of us my
brother sister and i lived with our mom
but that was a difficult thing that was
a that created a loneliness
did you did you realize that at the time
did you realize the impact that incident
had had on you growing up
probably not
no i think i
that you don't when you're lonely you
don't really age eight or nine or twelve
you don't really know you're lonely you
just you don't feel whole i suppose
you don't feel completely whole other
people seem to be jollier than i was at
that age that's for sure
as an adult did you ever
look back and try and understand the
significance of that particular event
and how it might have shaped you i think
the event
i don't know if it's shaped me but it's
definitely added um
a complexity to my character which has
made me
which has helped shape my my my
relationship with people my relationship
with work my relationship with
everything yeah there's no doubt it
would be
silly to pretend that it didn't
reminds me of something that um i talk
about this guy a lot this guy said to me
he came on this podcast he was michael
jordan and kobe bryant's trainer
and he talked about how
some of the things that happened to us
early that are traumatic end up
being the cause of our what he called
light side which is the talent our
brilliance the thing we become known for
but they're also the contributor to our
dark side which can be our complexity
our insecurities all of those kinds of
things
um
do you think that event so early on or
any event early on in your life
that particular event let's focus on
that particular event hadn't
contributing factor to what people would
consider to be your brilliance this
incredible career you've had
listen i think i think people people
work people become obsessive and they
become successful and they work
extremely hard for all kinds of
different reasons
they want to become relevant they want
to be
they want maybe
to be careful or seek admiration they
didn't get or they have parents who
didn't acknowledge them i really i don't
know all i know is it must have probably
had of course it had some effect on the
way i've i work and the view my life and
have lived my life yeah
but i but i think um over time over over
many years it's
it's it it's waned
um as i've
as i've kind of developed
as a person
i i also i'm right i'm nervous about
even suggesting that
you know to be fulfilled and to make
change and to really contribute to
society you have to come from a dark
place because i don't think you do
um
certainly not as as dark as something
like that
i you know i i think about when i meet a
lot of obsessive people it tends to be
the case that something quite uh extreme
had poked them yeah in their life at
some point to make them give them that
chip on their shoulder yeah whether it's
michael jordan or kobe or whether it's
eddie hearn yeah and that feeling of
living in his father's shadow and the
insecurity of that and these other you
know the sons of billionaires that i
meet who've built big fashion empires
yeah they're very um they're very
dominant fathers have have made them
incessive obsessive by convincing them
vicariously that they're not good enough
for example and so that's why i always i
always tend to go in search of
understanding what
where that obsessive is you're right
dude there's there's bound to be a
correlation as you know from all the all
so many of the people you've interviewed
and you're clearly very empathetic that
you will find a a train a common
denominator there but it's not
it's it's not everything it's certainly
not for for a great many people
listening or watching who who have not
faced tragedy or sadness like that um
they need to know that it's it's not an
essential part of being able to get on
and and do do good do extraordinary work
what about your father
my father was uh he was quite distant my
father um
[Music]
he was kind of old-fashioned
my parents were very very different my
mother was ukrainian
immigrant uh and and
kind of wild and wonderful and my father
was really kind of iris posh
aristocratic instrument rather distant
and cold
he then made a mistake of marrying um
someone for a very short period of time
when i was about 10 11 that that ended
very that did not end well for any of us
uh the three children um
so it's not a great time between seven
and and sixteen it was a messy a messy
uh childhood i think
did you live with problems
did you ever go in search of
answers as to why your mother
made that decision
ah
no i i i didn't
i didn't because not not that many
people knew my mother actually we we
lived alone with her um
i
she was just she was
just had serious mental issues
because she was
just ill
and and sad and and it's awful you know
terrible terrible it's common i mean
listen it's common this happens all the
time
um
this happens too much
um
too much too common
that that distance from um
the absence of both parents that's
that's kind of what i've ascertained
from what you said so far there was an
absence of
of both parents to some degree
what i i i resonate with that for my own
reasons yeah i um my mum was was working
so hard that she decided to end up
sleeping in the shop so i was i'm the
youngest of four as well and typically
what you find i think is the youngest
one gets treated like the older ones
yeah at a certain point especially if
it's a boy and so by the age of 10
neither of my parents are there when i
wake up and neither of them are there
when i go to sleep on one hand that
gives me great independence yeah it
means that i stop going to school yeah
because no one's going to punish me if i
don't yeah um and that is maybe in my
case what led me to becoming in my view
an entrepreneur there was a void of um
responsibility or sort of accountability
which led to independence so i started
selling things and doing what i liked
that made me very bad at following rules
later in life which i think is i'm going
back and connecting the dots in
hindsight but i think that led me to be
able to i'm sure that's true that would
make complete sense um so both of us
have that in common
but then you know so so do a great many
others
um
in addition to my i had a real problem
with authority i went to really
old-fashioned schools i was sent away to
schools age seven and in both cases the
schools were really really old-fashioned
and in my opinion terribly badly run
with all kinds of
bad things going on it was just shocking
so i had a really bad relationship with
authority i felt it completely let me
down on every level
um i still do actually
so maybe that's why i branched out on my
own early to try and i just
you know
so many of us
are let down by
people in power and authority i find
you know it's sad it's irritating it
really is irritating actually it doesn't
matter if it's people who run companies
or people in politics or people who run
schools it's just
particularly schools i think
um
people who are in charge of young
children need to nurture them and look
after them and help them build their
confidence and strength
not put them through a meat grinder
that's what happened in your school
the uh the first uh private school i
went to was
just just shocking yeah really really
i didn't want to go into it because it
would just
upset your view of your view
i want to hear it no no no i'm not going
to go there i refuse together but it was
just not a good
experience not a good place and so that
that's where i think i learned very very
early on to seriously distrust authority
and deeply
and and perhaps then realize okay you've
got to forge your own path and work with
people who you trust and people who are
worthy of your your love
and people who give back
rather than people who
you know climb that ladder into
positions of authority
but
a great many of us
suffer from this a great many of us are
working
our asses off for people who don't
really
support us or appreciate us or want to
develop our characters or skills or
anything
so
commerce is selfish
the people who do well in commerce
if you look at your success
90 of it is because of your
your understanding of the way human
beings work
it's about giving and taking and giving
and thinking long term
that's what really builds success
i think
i really do i mean one advantage i have
my father
used to spend a lot of time uh
entertaining very very kind of powerful
people particularly from america and and
i realized they were in the end mostly
just pretty average human beings but it
achieved a lot
and i started seeing them with all their
faults and warts and realizing wow
to make a difference
it's not impossible
but you need the right structure and i
think so many of us work in a structure
which is simply not possible
whether it be politics or fear or our
own insecurities or whatever it is
there's just not enough transparency in
this world
you know a great many of
us are working with no transparency at
all in in our place of work
don't you think
i get the feeling you
you you thrive off transparency you like
it you face things head-on and you like
people around you to face things head-on
that's that's the way to build
it's the only way
yeah i've been on a journey i think i
think when i was a bit more insecure i
think transparency felt like a risk and
then as i've developed my in myself and
also in my businesses transparency felt
like a great motivator yeah and i
actually said to my team some of which
are in the room now
at the start of this month
that every quarter i'm going to show you
all the financials of our entire
business so you can see everything and
also you're going to see that i've never
taken a pound out of this business ever
because i want them to understand
because in that that's an example of for
me transparency in a business context
being a real big big motivator then one
of the younger girls in the team when i
was in the car one day turned to me and
said by the way you doing that
completely changed my perception because
i think yeah i think they thought that
like i was making this money from doing
this podcast or whatever it is or my
business and then taking the money into
my pocket from as it comes in so to show
them that i've never taken a penny ever
i it kind of i think
yeah
aligns us no no listeners transparency
and people being open and honest and
building trust is by far the most
important characteristic
ever for the day i started my work for
the last 40 years i've now realized it's
what you should value and crave more
than anything it's worth everything
transparency is everything and so many
people work in an environment we're
simply not there they're just not used
to it they can't expect it they can't
demand it and they're not going to get
it and that's bad
move job change
don't don't don't you shouldn't work for
people who aren't transparent
and that's
transparency is a wonderful thing you
get some honesty a truth truth is
wonderful can you define your definition
of what you mean when you're saying
transparency
well
i mean to keep it really simple let's
let's let's stick to the world of
commerce and the world of commerce is
and probably politics but i don't know i
have no understanding of politics and
i've no inkling ever to be a politician
but
in the world of commerce there's not
nearly as much transparency as this
should be so sharing information sharing
truth saying what you feel
um being honest with your
your your colleagues your teammates as
well as the people who work with you and
for you it's just
you can't take that that stuff for
granted because it doesn't happen in
most places
you i don't know you need a collective
um you need you need uh
you need to to um
i don't know why
you tell me why why do you think 90 of
businesses are not nearly as transparent
as they should be and could be we know
what they are it's all about people
protecting their own fears it's about
their own insecurities about protecting
their own pay their bonuses there are a
thousand reasons why there's not the
transparency we deserve as human beings
because
to achieve the truth so say like i'm
just for as an example say i run an
organic
um vegetable store yup
i can on one hand
go to the extra effort of actually being
organic which means it costs me more i
have to do a bunch of stuff in the
supply chain whatever or i can say i am
and
get the same return exactly
two decades ago
it would be very hard for you to find
out i was lying because the world wasn't
connected with the internet there was no
glass doors social media tweeting
instantaneous communication so i think
the world of business grew in a black
box approach where
your your pr your marketing your
messaging was painted out on the outside
of your business by the marketing
director we're now in a glass box world
where everybody can see inside and they
can talk with someone in australia in
a second so i think that there's been
this i think transparent businesses in
the last 10 years
in the connected world have really won
um for that reason okay
there's no doubt it's much harder to lie
with the gut to your consumers there's
no question but i'm more interested in
in the lies that deceit and and the the
lack of transparency and the darkness
with the relationships people have with
their employees
and their employer
where a great deal of stuff is never
said
well i mean how many people do what is
the percentage of people who wake up on
a monday morning want to go to work i
mean it's frighteningly small why do you
think that is i mean if if 80 percent of
the people who you work with
you find out they didn't want to come to
work wouldn't you find that devastating
wouldn't surely wouldn't you look in the
mirror and say what on earth am i doing
wrong
i think if that was the case i also
wouldn't want to come to that place of
course you wouldn't
but the thing is now you've got to ask
yourself why does that apply to
70 of all working people and what are
they meant to do how do we sitting here
around this round table what do we mean
how can we help them
how can we help nurture a thing where
people have got the courage to be
transparent and say what they feel
what do you think the answer is i don't
know
but but we're living in a times where
it's beginning to happen
i mean listen just look at the metoo
movement who would have thought a few
years ago that could have generated the
speed and power it did it's an
incredibly good thing
i mean you know
that went from
i dare not say anything to the whole
world saying everything in just one year
two years
it's fantastic
there's a small example of absolutely
zero transparency
sick
power corrupt
this awful thing
but we know this is true
we know it's true as you're a boss you
you know you have a position of huge
responsibility you know
i know we all know that
what about affection
what is affection one of the things that
one of the things that was definitely
absent from my childhood was affection i
didn't even call my parents mum and dad
i still don't to this day
um their absence i think was one part of
that but also just i didn't have
affection so growing up the thought of
calling someone a friend yeah a best
friend
still to this day makes me cringe
it's just a little bit
yeah in your case
are you an affectionate person i
i've never been asked that question i
have absolutely no idea
how to answer it um
because do i compare myself to other
people
um
i have no idea you don't know if you're
affectionate or not
i think i'm affectionate
in your own way but
i also know for years i struggled with
my like like so many with self-esteem
and you know um and i i i'm sure i felt
completely unlovable for decades
probably i'd i'm sure
um
but then you know i i've had
in my opinion uh i've been blessed with
amazing relationships with friends and
and and family i mean just completely
blessed and and and i'm not a baby so
i'm six you know i'm 62 years old and so
this
you know i've
two of my children work with me
uh i mean what more could you possibly
dream of than that so
i must have some relationship with the
concept of affection
how where it came from when how i grew
it i i'm not entirely sure because i
certainly didn't get it from my mother
and father i must have got it from
from from close friends and and maybe
just looking and learning that there's
no point
trying to go through life without it
what you what you give you get back you
know pratimagi started you know as like
it became a kind of incredible family
and the warmth and love and care which
went into the building of relationships
and that company was breathtaking it was
like a family where it started with one
store and ended up with hundreds but
there was a time when it was truly
extraordinary extended family and that's
i think where i grew
to understand the power of of of of
deep
affection love and trust
yeah it definitely came for me much
later than for most people yeah
you said there was you think there was
probably decades where you didn't love
yourself yeah well i mean decades as in
in my teens and then in my 20s
um
you i don't know how good you are at at
reflecting and self-discovery i'm i'm
kind of a five out of ten probably
i i mean i i pushed myself therapy and
and even doing this i think called the
hoffman have you heard about it he's
coming here yeah i did the hoffman he's
kind of great he's what a genius that
guy was but
so i try
what was your question or how long the
decades of self-loathing i don't know no
not how long just what were the symptoms
of of that
just just probably um
just that ongoing feeling of being
completely unworthy
that's what you get when you don't have
parents
so much or
loving
you're not nurtured you know
so you feel lonely
you grow up with that
that feeling of
unworthiness
and i always believe i i actually wrote
it i think in my book on my notepad or
something that the things that made us
feel invalid when we're younger end up
being the things we seek validation from
when we're older that's
complete common sense and true
what so did you feel unloved
it was i knew my parents loved me that
we just didn't have i just didn't learn
what affection was so like think about i
don't even call them dad and mum today i
didn't learn what it was i also because
their relationship
was incredibly
dis like loud and so i've said this a
million times before it's in my book my
mom would scream my dad for seven hours
a day my mom is african she can really
hit some notes and my dad would sit
there he's a he's a guy from coventry
you know he was a middle-aged white man
and he would just be totally silent and
that was my model of relationships if
you're with a woman you are in prison so
i i didn't get into relationships 27.
yeah yeah so i learned all of those
models and then you know i would chase i
would chase women when i was young i
would chase women when i was 14. i would
chase women when i was 21. the minute
they turned to me and said yes
i would dissuade them i'd immediately
talk them out of it
but why do you think that's because once
you had them you felt that you didn't
deserve their affection or was it just
the competition of getting them to prove
that you were worthy of them because was
it i would pursue them because of the
reasons why we pursue anyone because
they're beautiful and i have those
hormones and there's that desire and i
you know i have that okay
the minute we got to commitment yeah
we're going to be boyfriend and
girlfriend so you were frightened of the
commitment i was i would have me
immediately felt like my dad trapped in
a cage
okay so i would dissuade them from it so
it was literally i it took me until i
was 25 to figure out what was going on
while i was running away from women that
i was chasing um the minute we got to
commitment boyfriend and girlfriend if
it made me my skin crawl and it made me
feel like i was trapped so i dissuade
them
so in your case
that could have just been because what
you witnessed 100 so over over years you
just witnessed this dysfunctional
relationship where in a way your father
was trapped so it kind of
so mine was different to that because i
never saw my parents together ever
i don't think i barely ever saw them in
the room together that's not quite true
my father used to come down occasionally
on sunday but i never saw them arguing
um
so
my my take on what love was and should
be was was
that must have been my own invention i i
don't know
but i've come to it's a fascinating
subject don't you think when you study
people who in uh supportive wonderful
relationships i find it enthralling i
mean fascinating
fascinating so the most fascinating
um thing to study
how
people
uh
adapt their life to be completely in
love with someone
and and and live their life
uh
just showing warmth and kindness and
forgiveness and love is very enriching
if you can do it
it's definitely something to um
it's a goal
it's a great goal
i mean it's a goal there are other girls
but that's got to be the greatest i
guess
i think we admire and others the things
we don't have in ourselves right so
people would look at you and go how the
hell the greatest goal is to build prep
and i would look at someone else and say
what you've just said i'd say the
greatest goal is to how the [ __ ] did you
stay together for 50 years when i'm
struggling to stay together for two or
one yeah
yeah i guess that's what makes life
fascinating in the sense that some
people can achieve the goals that that
you and i think are really very very
difficult but doesn't stop us
stop us struggling to get there what was
the consequence then of you you growing
up being in your early 20s and not
feeling like you were quote-unquote sort
of enough
was that what did you see well on the
dark side i guess it made me focus more
and and
and made me more determined i guess more
determined uh
just it's it where most people uh
packed off and went home i would i would
i'd be prepared to stick it out
um but you can't i had an interesting
conversation with someone the other day
about the use of this expression hard
work he said it's not hard work it's not
it's it's a great many people work very
very hard
and they don't um
it's it's not that it's about
it's about
the evidence it's about can you make
change are you getting better is your
product better is your service better is
your relationship with the people you
work with is it better you know it's
about proof it's about real facts it's
not just hard work hard work
we just use that expression i work
really hard i know a lot of people who
work really really hard but they don't
work in the focus way that you and i
work
so it's it's worth kind of thinking well
what is the difference between them and
us what is it
and if we have to guide anyone if that
if they seek if they already are in a
rich wonderful relationship and they
want to run a company their own company
they want to be self-employed how can we
guide them
what is it that we have that they don't
um and would we swap their wonderful
rich incredible relationship
to have another 500 employees i'm not
sure
i i think you can have both oh that's
what i i
um that's my goal
you know i i i'm determined to have both
determined to have both
you don't have to have one without the
others not true
i mean it's hard to have both but come
on
it's gotta be worth aiming for isn't it
do you have both now yeah
not not in full because my career is
only half there and i'm
oh i'm not running out of steam but it's
so annoying i'm running out of time
um and my relationship with my you know
i have seven kids i've got
four step kids three of mine i've got uh
how long have we been together 15 years
brook and i mean yeah i'm i'm bloody
lucky
i'm really fortunate i think i i think i
picked really well
um
you know i'm bloody lucky with that
but i mean i could blow it i guess but
i'm gonna do my damnedest not to
when you look back at um starting prep
we're talking about what's driving you
there was there any epiphanies around
what was really driving you on that day
when
someone first came along and said they
were going to buy your company because
for me i thought i was being driven by
money until someone offered me it
and i thought oh god
there must be something else motivating
me here i don't know about that myself
it's
i've often wondered did money
and the pursuit of money ever driving i
don't think so because i think i saw
enough people when i was young with a
lot of money who are absolutely
miserable and dysfunctional and
miserable actually my mother had a lot
of money and lot obviously lost it all
and died
so there i had a very good example of of
someone with a huge amount of money who
had nothing well i didn't we didn't
inherit any of her money but
she was um it was a good example of
someone who's miserable with money money
doesn't
it's awful uh you know when people like
you and i say money doesn't make you
happy it's nothing more irritating
there's a statement like that when a
great many people uh don't have a large
cash reserves in their bank account but
the fact is uh we both know that it
doesn't what was motivating you well i
think i wanted to make a difference i
wanted to be relevant i wanted to be
admired
yeah i wanted to do something
interesting and great i wanted to people
i wanted people to look at me and think
wow he's
this this guy's serious he's on to
something
he matters
then i wanted to to
create these important relationships
with people i worked with i wanted to
see people flourish around me that
really mattered to me i wanted to try
and wipe away all the some of that pain
i wanted that and then deep down i
really love and passionately creative
the creative process of what i did so
the design and the food and the taste
and the look and the feel and and
breaking down every barrier which i just
as far as i was i only kind of saw
opportunity
you have to be very resourceful and
determined
in in my particular business
you know because it's
as we as we were saying before and it's
basic if you want to sell the best cake
in the world at the best price you've
got to be damn resourceful you've got to
work with geniuses you have the best
equipment the best everything
and and that doesn't happen overnight
you don't get that by picking up the
phone and ordering something you have to
create it
and it's you have to be
unbelievably resourceful
but i i that with regard to the food the
design and my belief in in what food
should be and could be for people um
knows no bounds no end no end i'll stop
at nothing
love it
those
dinner parties
your father threat yeah yeah did they
have any lasting impression or lasting
impact well no most of the time i was in
the kitchen actually so i'd meet these
these remark these many remarkable
people but my love of food started
because i used to spend all the time in
the kitchen and there was a a guy used
to come and cook he was really talented
tony and i'd spend the night with him
watching him work from the age of about
14 13.
it was fascinating and that's really
where my love of food started with him
watching him work so it was a
combination of of of becoming obsessed
with what food could be and should be
um and at the same time
not being frightened of of all these
rather dysfunctional but immensely
successful people who i met
through my father i didn't really get to
know them very well but a few
at the time it's hard to determine when
you're building a business and it's
going well it's hard to determine at the
time what's actually making it brilliant
and the specialness as you've called it
before in hindsight i think it's much
easier to look back and go that's why
we were special and different that's why
we won when you look back at prep at
business you ended up selling for two
billion or something crazy a huge number
yeah okay it doesn't matter it's a huge
number um what was the specialness what
what did you
unintentionally intentionally do right
what was the
well certain amount of it it wasn't
planned
it happened
endless moments of magic endless moments
of of
moments of bizarre creativity and
confidence exactly the same with with
your business it just it's so difficult
it was you didn't write it all down and
plan it it just it happened with moments
of confidence endless endless moments
you know of swimming upstream as all the
fish are going in one way you suddenly
look around you think damn it i'm going
to go the other way
i'm not going to swim
in this direction this can't be right
and that takes guts it takes bravery it
takes relationships with people it takes
hiring talent you have to have the guts
to hire talent people's often much
better than you you've got to prepare to
listen and listen until it hurts you've
got to be prepared to fail over and over
and over again
i love failure i love it
because it's just a damn journey
i really love it i fail every day
and i don't care about it i just get on
with it it's wonderful
um but with prep
food is a magical thing to be able to do
it's like music or film i mean it's
it's it's because when we know it's good
it's wonderful
it's wonderful
and in those days in 1986 when we
started it was in the doldrums it was
also boring and awful
um so it was just a question of
but but prep wasn't just built with food
it was built with a combination was kind
of built with a
magical magic approach to the
the respect and love and obsession about
creating pride and trust within with the
with the team with employees i i was
obsessed by that obsessed by that
actually how how important was it for
you that you were naive because i think
naive oh it's very important i had no
idea what i was doing
none why was that i have no idea what
i'm doing most of the time actually
because i spend my life casting myself
out into never never land i know what
i'm doing half the time but you learn
you listen you talk you speak to the
right people and you learn
because to create something new how
you know
you've got to you've got to put yourself
in slightly uncharted territory
you know and then you've got to be
prepared to fail many many times and
keep going
that's all prep was just a series of
hundreds of failures that's all it was
moments of failure and then moments of
glory moments of
wonderful moments
of bravery yeah that was it like you you
know exactly what i'm talking about it's
moments endless moments where light goes
on you think okay i'm going to take that
risk i'm going to do it
it feels right something in your heart
says it's
go for it
it could be
it could be
working with people promoting people or
giving them extraordinary opportunity or
or developing something which no one's
ever eaten before or i don't know
hundreds of different things
or when systems don't work and you're
not getting
you're not getting the behaviors or the
warmth or the trust you crave then you
have to think outside the box you got to
think again
we used to
there was one store after about 10 the
10th pressure i think i i couldn't
understand why the atmosphere in this
store was so bad fleet street oh it's
fleet street yep bloody hell and it was
the first time i had paid a recruitment
company for a top manager suit and tie
the whole thing
and yeah it's true i met this girl who i
recognized who worked in the store a
young scruffy girl on the tube on the
way home she burst into tears and she
said i'm leaving on monday
because her manager was a dick
and i didn't need her to explain what
dick meant i knew exactly what she meant
my god i'd been at school
i'd been all the teachers were dicks
i knew exactly what she meant and i
hated
i hated the idea of this this determined
brave
trustworthy wonderful loving fabulous
young lady
being bullied by dick
so we we fired the dick and we promoted
her to a manager and i never looked back
i think i learned more from that young
lady than any anyone i've ever learned
in my life actually
the hope and the joy did you see
yourself in her
oh my god i've never thought about that
oh my god maybe
but no one ever gave me that opportunity
i had to fight for it i didn't give her
that opportunity she earned it actually
she earned it
just by being herself
she was a great manager too actually i
don't know how i knew i wasn't i didn't
know she was going to be a great manager
there was something about her
there was something about her and by the
way there's something about
a great great many people i meet they
all have
so much going for them they just don't
believe it they're just not working in
an environment where they're giving the
opportunity they deserve
people don't trust them
people don't nurture them because
they're too busy being selfish nurturing
them themselves
sounds like you're talking about your
school teachers oh well they're just
they were idiots they were just
complete idiots
and they're just downright no one should
be they shouldn't have been
paid
but a lot of authorities like that
i mean a lot
and that stores sales doubled or
something oh my god yeah double triple
yeah of course
why because there was there was trust
there was care there was pride there was
love and forgiveness there was goals
there was there was everything wonderful
in life right there
right there
business isn't just business to you is
it it's not just about the money
no and it shouldn't be to anyone but it
is because we worked short-term goals
so many of us are controlled but bossed
around
we have to we're
you know people's emotions are
incredibly inconvenient in commerce
aren't they let's face it
and and some people like you and other
people have found ways
of being
you know
find ways of of of bypassing all that
[ __ ]
and you let people
be themselves you actually encourage
people to be themselves to speak up
to be transparent
that's what you need that shot was
completely transparent it was beautiful
and that's what builds
great great companies or great teams or
great sports teams to know what it is or
makes great movies it doesn't matter or
anything
people need that feeling of uh
sense of purpose and trust
uh openness i think funny you talk much
more in terms of culture than you do in
terms of tactics and tricks and
discounting and these kinds of things
seems to start more with culture with
you
yeah i think it's it's if you're trying
to break down barriers and do things new
which i've now spent the last 20 years
really taking on almost
an extraordinary wonderful challenge
which we will we will win we will get
there with it soon yeah it's a
affordable nutritious food
and it is reinventing itself over and
over and over again i mean it's 20 years
old and it's had three reinventions that
the latest ones are beginning to be to
really pay i mean they're really
wonderful
because the world
the europe are the cities in which we
live desperately need affordable
nutritious food we are half 40 percent i
think plant-based
our entire menu is under 500 calories
most of it's under 400 you know this is
what people need we can't go on in this
in the developed world being 50 percent
of obese or something whatever it is now
it's shocking
but this is we can't blame anyone for
this there's no point blaming there's no
point even blaming us there's no one to
blame
but it's about
my responsibility i think
is with my team to carry on
pioneering the the systems and the and
the system to make it possible to sell
really nutritious good food for for
seven quid
it's possible you talked about hiring
and the importance of people and the
right people there one of the things
that i read that you'd done very early
on with prep was
to
allow the current employees to
sign off on an incoming team member so
when someone comes for an interview the
people that decide if that person is
going to get a job are the current team
members yeah so we the office used to
pay for for
we did interview people um we'd go
through the list of
of the shops which the predator managers
which needed
people coming up and we'd send them
there
and they would spend the whole day there
paid and at four o'clock no one would
know they wouldn't know this but at four
o'clock all the the staff would vote on
a napkin yes or no so they go around the
whole team that we would find ways of of
getting as many people to spend 25
minutes with them as possible and then
at uh four o'clock they'd vote and then
we'd ring the person up you got it or
you didn't and why why was that you
because
uh i wish i'd been able to do that at
school because i realized after about
seven or eight it was dysfunctional that
you only needed a slightly not
particularly reliable or trustworthy
manager and what would they do they'd
hire the people they wanted
the whole system would just be abused
and there were
a couple of examples where that was
happening and it just made me sick
because it was so bad for the team it
was bad for the culture it was
bad for the manager and it was really
bad for the customers so i i just
created this simple system which was so
beautiful it was beautiful because young
people
were voting on other people's lives
within a few weeks of starting that was
great empowering them trusting them that
was great good for them huh really good
for them
small details you know when i read
through your story of both your
businesses all your businesses i noticed
that there's a real eye for detail you
know if i think about itsu and the
orchards you have there you have real
orchards in the itsu's right
could very well fake them like i do i
mean i'm pretty sure there's some fake
orchards in here there's definitely some
fake orchards upstairs yeah you went for
the real ones in prayer one of the
things that's ultimately defined the
brand called culture at the right time
is the fact that the food is all
completely fresh so none of it has a
cell by date it doesn't stay there until
tomorrow ever these small
sort of concerns with detail
how defining have they been for you in
hindsight because sometimes people are
told not to sweat the small stuff yeah
okay so quite a lot of this stuff is to
me at the time it's just kind of obvious
in other words
if your product if you want expect your
customers to be loyal to you
you've got to treat them with treat them
with respect you've got to sell them
something worth worthy of their
hard-earned money but people care about
the bottom line give that cost you more
money now that's ridiculous i'm not a
very good accountant i i know
i don't i'm not interested in
in the numbers of the at all i'm far
more interested in the relationships
with the customer and the staff and the
product the numbers are just look after
themselves
they really really really do and anyway
i've always been lucky to be
to have wonderful brilliant people
around me who are much better than i at
numbers i hate numbers they're so boring
i shouldn't say that because without the
numbers you can't grow so i feel very
strongly that we have to have numbers
which enable us to grow because if we
can grow we can feed more people and
then we can give opportunities
someone's told you that after the fact
yeah i can tell that's not that wasn't
your default position it was a bit
exactly but i find the numbers awfully
boring compared to the product and the
relationships with the people
um
they're just like a school report in a
way aren't they um if you want to give
away and refuse to keep all your
sandwiches to the next day and what's
more drive them in a van to the homeless
people who need them clearly they've got
to be delicious
you know got a taste good enough so
people will pay 50p more or 30p more and
that's just basic common sense isn't it
i think the whole numbers thing's
reasonable it's just common sense
so you never even you at pratt you
didn't even throw the food away you
would drive it in advance yeah we had to
even when we were making no profits we
had a van to take it to the homeless you
know every of course yeah because you
can't expect people to make this stuff
to make the food with pride and then
throw it away yeah we obsessed about not
not not throwing it away you can't can't
throw it away
uh
and then if you
take the piss out of your customers
you'll lose them
don't you find it extraordinary how
often you get shocking service where
you've spent a lot of money and no one
gives a damn
i'm not going to name big companies but
i can think of some companies where i've
spent five or six thousand pounds on
something and they don't answer
i mean it can be shocking and they still
don't care
oh my god i will answer every customer
now today if customers write to me i'll
answer them before i go to bed no
question
at prep the other thing that was quite
i remember hearing about and thinking oh
that's cool and different is one in
every 100 coffees or something you would
give away no it wasn't that no it was
much more than that like was it okay so
we didn't have a loyalty scheme for
years and years and years because we
we couldn't quite know what to do and i
couldn't but what i realized is uh very
very early on
i think in prep number 12 or something
we said i know that what we'll just
really encourage everyone who works
there to give
whatever they want away to whoever they
want to
um
it was wonderful
we used to do these things called buddy
days
well the whole office used everyone had
a buddy shop
and um
and my buddy shot was oxford but we used
to
you could give away five or six or ten
products every single day to anyone a
regular customer someone who had a long
face
someone you fancied it just didn't
matter give because when you do good
stuff it always comes back
you get it back you've got to think long
term
and so this was a good example of where
we
begged everyone who worked for us just
be kind give it away they
exceed the expectations of customers
they'll come back
and you know what should i tell the most
extraordinary thing some of the most
profitable shops short term short term
we found weren't giving anything away so
the manager was saying to us no no no no
giveaways no giveaways
because their margins their profit
margin was better so we introduced a
button on the till called the joy of
pratt i didn't do this clive did this he
introduced a system whereby
at the press of a button on the computer
could tell us every single store which
wasn't giving away enough
because when you gave something away you
had to press you register on the till as
a giveaway so we quickly found out all
the managers who were being who were
running their businesses too tight they
were being a bit mean
they thought
they were doing a good job by delivering
more profit what what they didn't
realize is no no to do a great job you
need to build a long-term relationship
with your staff and your your customers
so give them a coffee give them a
question just do it
do you have any evidence numerically to
support that that worked no
none
zero
and everyone used to come in
professionals and consultants just say
this is ridiculous what are you doing
your loyalty scheme is a joke
and i just
what can you say
just
no
it works great
but but it can't it you know
different different
it works great but you can't prove it
that's the typical ceo thing it's like
trying to explain it to a cfo it's just
like yeah just believe
just believe it
the only reason we're sitting here now
you and i is because
multiple times we've just made decisions
like this
um
half the time we've had to pretend to
people we work with we know what we're
talking about whenever we have
completely no idea but if it feels right
and you think long term you do it you
just persuade them you pretend you know
you justify in hindsight yeah of course
you find some study find some study or
just say let's try it and then and then
no and then finally say we're gonna try
it
i i wonder sometimes about how you know
in your story and in my story um how our
traumas and how our experiences with
authority or with our parents or with
shitty corporate jobs we had ended up
shaping the decisions we made in our
businesses and defining us because
that's why i referenced naivete not
knowing the correct answers and in some
cases having a problem with rules and
authority end up creating a more modern
culture that i think so yeah i'm sure i
see it over and over again eventually
all the crap we went through definitely
helped us
uh break through and just
just do things differently must do yes
when you know something doesn't work why
not just try something else
that's why founder led businesses even
you know you think about steve jobs
perspective on the world to remove that
keyboard and to do those small decisions
that they made maybe it was driven by
ego insecurity or whatever
but it but for some reason it gives
people courage of their convictions to
create new things yeah new ways
and also a never-ending pursuit for the
the better detail
to make something better
and it's endless that's the thing about
the food it is truly endless why did i
read that you don't like ambitious
managers in your business i read that
you like slow and beautiful growth very
ambitious people are a pain in the ass
often very ambitious people often not
always but often a very short term
and they're really
hiding all their crap for their own
personal
their own personal gain which i
understand they've got they've got their
own goals they've got their own desires
they've got their own dreams of their
own house this car this house this
school this whatever the hell it is
but that can be incredibly destructive
to someone like
myself and my team and an organization
which i take like a 30 year view to
everything i do
i really do 30 years which drives must
drive some people i work with up the
wall but i really like to think 30 years
30 years must be and if you if you get
someone who's very powerful in your
business who's thinking three years well
i mean look at that look and that's
that's quite common in commerce as you
know
so they can they can they can move
mountains and but
but then the mountains crumble
that's boring it's a waste of everyone's
energy and passion
and love and everything
in may 2018 you sold your final stake in
pratt yeah
why
because um i wasn't oh i wasn't asked um
i had no choice uh the the the the new
owners of pressure manager have nothing
to do with me i met them i've met them
once for five minutes they they probably
think i'm an absolute idiot they have no
i've never met them don't they have no
interest in working with me
that's their choice it's completely
you know
that that is um that's their choice
i hope it works for them
so you own the business with your
co-founder and then so that's a long
yeah it's a long story prep started in
86 and yeah and
i'm trying to i bought a founder in who
was who i who i met at uh at college
um who was much much cleverer than me
much more disciplined than me
and i had this really strong vision of
of wanting to do this but i knew i was
smart enough back then to know i needed
someone who was respectful of numbers
and discipline and the law
so i said to him look if you leave your
job i'll give you half this company and
he did he was brave he had a good job
and he left his job
um
and i think probably in the end after
about 15 years we we've become immensely
successful
the two of us and he wanted to retire
i think the pace that my endless
never-ending
pushing on the vision of what this could
be probably drove him mental um
but he he he was smart he retired
he works a bit now but he kind of
retired completely
which i respect completely that was his
choice did it suck at the time when
sinclair told you that he was going to
retire no no no no he was i rather
admired him
i could never do that i really admire
people who who are able to take control
of their life like that i can't
are you being dragged what's that mean
being tracked yeah so take control of
their life like that so no no i
genuinely i promise you i think people
who are able to to
take control and i'm gonna go walking in
the in the bloody jungle for six months
i have nothing but admiration for people
who can do that so let's ask if you're
being dragged because
like we said earlier you're admiring
something that you don't have yourself
yeah i don't have it
i don't have it i'm i'm you don't have
control of your life i do have control
over my life because i definitely make
the choice to do what i do and i
couldn't stop and i love it i really i'm
happiest creating
there's no question i'm completely in
love with what i do i love it i really
enjoy it
that may sound weird but it's the truth
i love it i don't want to be walking in
the jungle i love doing what i'm doing
every day i've just had a food meeting
now it was fantastic we've cracked
something we've been working on for a
year we cracked it today it's incredible
and millions of people will eat this
thing in a year from now and it's
because of our relentless
passion and hard work to get this thing
right and today we i think we cracked it
and that's wonderful
and then earlier this morning we cracked
a bit of design which was incredible i
really enjoy it so i don't want to be in
the jungle he did he wanted to retire
and i respect that but it left me in the
ship because we didn't have any
paperwork between us and and suddenly uh
different kinds of people came into the
business and they were much more formal
and and some of the joy went out of it
did he sell his steak at that point uh
yeah he sold a chunk of it but it really
changed it became professional
uh and then and then private equity came
in i mean we had a very good
private equity company a uk one they
were they were fine they were very
honorable decent people but it was
definitely um
the business became
more about becoming a very successful
business than than developing a very
beautiful relationship with the customer
and staff and it was acquired by
mcdonald's no that's not true no what
happened is um for a very short period
of time donald's owned a thirty percent
of it okay because i thought mcdonald's
or no i didn't
at the time the leader the ceo of the
business persuaded me that mcdonald's
would teach us the disciplines we didn't
have about global expansion
and i in the end he kind of caved in and
i thought it was a pretty weird idea but
i caved in
but after it was pretty obvious after a
few months it was a bad idea because
you know just they didn't really
understand our business
but i'll tell you what there was a very
very powerful distinction between
a pursuit of real beauty of a product
and a relationship with your customers
and your staff to running a business
and and generating
sales
striving at two different outcomes right
two completely different
a really clever person can do both
and we did do both the business was then
run by a friend of mine who's i still
work with now i have huge respect for
and he did a great job but
in the end the business was then of
course sold
in 2001 was it 18 18. yeah and will the
business continue to thrive i i don't
know i hope so i just honestly don't
know but they certainly don't want
anything to do with me are you
disappointed in the way the business is
moving
i'm not disappointed but do you ever
walk in there and go because i know i
did when i left my company when i
resigned my company had gone public and
i remember walking seeing things they're
doing and seeing seeing the office and
hearing this story and thinking oh [ __ ]
they've lost this no no no i think on
the whole for years the relationship
between the company and its members of
staff has been wonderful so i'm often
inspired by that and i've never no i
never think that i think i don't i know
you never walked in and gone if i was
still running no i don't really what i
think i sometimes go in and think wow i
wonder what just think what that could
be
and then i think god how complicated
that would be to get it there and thank
god i'm not doing both because that's
what i'm doing on a daily basis now with
with itsu because itsu will become in
fight ten years from now
a really remarkable home for affordable
nutritious food that's it's that's what
it will be there's no question that's
what it is becoming
it's hard to see that right now because
it sells too much uh raw fish uh you
know 30 of our sales are a product which
it used to be ninety percent it uh it's
now down to 50 i think or something
but we're changing and developing uh all
the time now far getting faster and
faster at the reinvention of the company
i couldn't quite figure out where the
crossover happened between itsu and
pratt when 97 the first itsu opened
while you were still there i was out and
and we had a supplier um a wonderful uh
the head of marketing at the japanese
center was a young japanese woman
and she said to me i said to her why day
why are you working for this terribly
boring company why don't you open a
japanese restaurant which is affordable
because in those days japanese
restaurants were really stuck up and
really expensive really boring
and
and she said to me okay i'll leave my
job
if you help
if you pay for it
so i said okay i'll pay for it you lose
your you you leave your job
i promised you two weeks later she rung
me up and said i've left my job
and i said what have you done what have
you
so i suddenly found myself with this
responsibility to open a restaurant
um so when we found a site and we opened
the first itsu which was very different
from what it is now but it was a start
and from that start we built
76 or something of of them and then
about five years ago we started
developing it so it could become
the future
but but we had to open 76 and keep it
private it was a 100 private company i
never ever again wanted to end up in a
situation where i owned a minority where
the business would take over in other
words you will do this you will do this
we will deliver these profits
and we don't care about your vision
so i was able to build it to such an
extent with the team that we owned it
all of it and now you have what 75
stores in total yeah
we're opening in lots of interesting
places really fascinating just now in
the next 12 months we're open i think we
open bromley next week but it's changing
so much
what's the worst crisis you've ever had
in your business
well i wasn't there
i'd left prep when the crisis happened
when the the the um sesame incident of
that poor girl who had food allergies i
wasn't there then that must have been
very difficult for everyone then
and and and the ups and downs as you
know as you would have experienced in
your business there are ups and downs
every week every month so you often
think this is a this is
funny enough i think most of my job
today is telling people not to worry a
lot of people i work with um come to me
and say that we're in terrible this is
nice
no it's not it's going to be fine
this sesame incident
yeah we're referring to is a young girl
yeah who had an allergic reaction to a
sesame
seed a baguette
in a big in a sheet she had serious food
allergies and she had bought without
her mother wasn't there and she bought a
baguette and ate it
which was covered in sesame seeds i mean
it was tragic
very really sad and as a result of that
natasha's law has changed
uh
brought in far more labeling food
labeling in this country it's called
natasha's law yeah after her
but it was very painful for her her
family and everyone uh
proud it was awful
but the crisis uh they'll come they can
fast and we'll be fine
we'll be fine
how can you be so sure
because
because
just stick to the truth
the truth is
you know
the truth is good
in the sense that
of all the things which could go
catastrophically wrong
we kind of know about them uh with
regard to the dangers of being on our
businesses uh
health and safety for instance we have a
five-star record of the highest record
in this country every single one is five
star always no one else has achieved
that before and that is because the head
of the ceo of our company has a
fantastic relationship with their head
of say it's awesome unbelievable if our
head of
safety got up on stage last week and the
entire
220 people just completely clapped it
says a lot because usually those people
you know
so there's culturally that says
something so health and safety in our
industry is really really a fear
um what else all kinds of things
did that incident with natasha she 15
year old drops dead on a plane from what
i read um did it change you in any way
did it make you think differently about
because that's for me that's the
inconceivable it almost reminds me of
um bob iger
i read disney yeah bob iger's book about
four-year-old that was playing at disney
and a crocodile comes out of the disney
pond and eats him no
yeah and and bob i get about to go up on
stage in asia gets a message from a
senior leadership team saying
a four-year-old at disney has just been
eaten by a crocodile
and
i mean it had a pretty profound impact
on him to say the least so
well
he was the chief exec at the time i know
that it was terribly hard for the the
senior team at practice although they
hadn't i mean they everything they'd
done was completely within the law
uh not that that too cares about that
but it was i mean it was
you know the the it was just
a number of terrible
things which which took place should
never have happened i had a few words to
say about one of my sponsors on this
podcast what you do now and how you do
it is slowly becoming redundant that's
the case for all industries but
education is the answer great teams are
only as good as the depth of their
combined knowledge so the more you learn
the more likely your team is to develop
and become even better at whatever you
do that's why i've partnered with
vodafone business because i understand
the importance of education throughout
the business journey their vhub has
everything you need in order to learn
and grow all completely free of charge
whether it's information on the latest
trends or being able to speak one-on-one
to a vhub digital advisor it's a great
place to start your learning journey go
and explore search v hub by vodafone on
google go check it out
a really remarkable thing happened um
in your life at a certain age when you
found out you had a daughter out of the
blue yeah
i had a feeling you were gonna ask about
that
that went public didn't it yes okay so
my yeah that is absolutely true and i
work with uh celeste now she's on the
board and she sits next to me two days a
week
uh and
it's incredible i had at some point in
my early life a man walked in he walked
into my my mum's shop
and he said
that he was my uncle turns out he was
yeah i didn't know i had any uncles in
this country turns out i did but tell me
about that day for you what how did it
happen how do you find out how what age
are you when you find out you have a
oh it's about 15 years ago and she was
20. i was about 45. you were 45 she was
20. no she was 19. oh 19. she had just
started at bristol university
and her mother called me who hadn't seen
for ages
um and obviously i had absolutely no
idea
that her daughter was my daughter no
absolutely no i'd never met her i'd had
no idea and her mother asked to see me
so i said yes me and we met and
we met in the king's road and she told
me i sat down i went you suspicious when
she asked to see you
no i wasn't suspicious i certainly
wasn't suspicious of that i thought
maybe she
needed help or i i don't know
um but she was a kind of cool
intelligent
rather wonderful eccentric brilliant
woman so i remembered her very fondly i
hadn't seen her for ages but so i met
her immediately and she and she just
told me there and then my daughter i
have a daughter and she's sure
she's your
daughter
so i asked
when did you tell her and how has it
gone down she said i told her two weeks
ago and not well
so then we then i tried to contact her
she was a bit
standoffish it was hard to get through
to her for a few days and then i drove
up to bristol university and we met
we met
and i had nothing but but um an
overwhelming desire to
a deep overwhelming desire to get in
there and and try my hardest
to build her muscle and her strength
and her you know what
what had happened to her was incredibly
unjust
and
i wanted from the depth of my heart to
do everything i could to try and repair
it and i will do that and continue that
to the dare die
i'm she's fantastic and she's really
close to my children and my other two
and
you know could be much worse but i feel
this is not an easy thing to go through
for her
not not an easy thing for anyone to go
through
so she's
strong she has she's married she has
two kids and a third one on the way and
she's really rather remarkable so the
person she thought was her father
wasn't wasn't correct
and why why
hadn't her mother told her to her father
because her mother she wasn't uh
when that when this happened uh they
they weren't close the mother and the
father they weren't they really weren't
close if you understand what i'm saying
they really weren't that close and he
the the father figure was pretty distant
through her life and when she got to the
age of 18 i think probably more distant
and i think the mother realized that
this couldn't go on forever and she the
mother was very brave she took this
hugely brave decision do i tell her the
truth or do i not i have nothing but
respect
and absolute admiration for the mother
having the courage to tell her daughter
the truth must have been agony
agony all round
but she did the right thing what was it
like arriving to bristol university that
day
oh what's it like when you you funny you
know when it when a child's yours i can
assure you you know immediately you just
know
so it was lovely
it was lovely i was really uh
funny enough things like that you would
have thought would be completely totally
um crushing for someone who wasn't that
well equipped to deal with
that subship but actually i found it one
really really really enriching and the
way my two boys embraced her was
incredible
it was really an opportunity to really
shine
and uh
and do and
it was great it's it's it's it's
you know
i have nothing but admiration for the
way
she's handled it
anyway she
let's change the subject because she
went like this
but you work together now which is
awesome yeah yeah of course we do she
she works in the marketing team she
leads marketing no she she leads the
brand and she's on the board and she's
been
extremely helpful from day one she ran
the marketing team for four years
actually she was bloody good at it
but now she has three children are about
to
sounds like a really nice movie to me
what are you scared of
uh what am i scared of
uh oh my god i'm scared of death really
i think
you didn't say he was kind i'm quite a
hypochondriac i'm scared of that
that's about it
maybe that's
that's about it where does death scare
you
no i think just just the whole thing
with health and not paying enough
attention to your
health and
and it's completely beyond one's control
i mean totally
when that goes you're in when that when
you're in trouble you're in trouble
and that can happen tomorrow
so that doesn't really scare me i don't
ponder on it too much
but i think we're all hypers
misha my son's a hyper my wife brooke is
not a hypo
shh i spent my life saying i'm dying she
and then
trouble i've cried wolf so many times
[Laughter]
and then one of my stepdaughters is
quite into medicine so i refer my
illnesses to her quite a lot
um only these illnesses real
certain so far we've had quite a lot of
false
we're not going to go there but the fact
is
yeah i i'm not even i'm not even feared
death now i don't fear i don't think i
fear anything actually i really don't
there's no time to fear
it's all time to hope
hope
and believe and hope and and yeah
the future
it's incredible what people can do not
just not me but all the people around me
if i had a recipe here and it's the
recipe of happiness what are the
ingredients on your recipe
listen i i i i
i
i don't think about it i really really
don't i can think about that i'm not
unhappy
i'm very very privileged and i'm very
lucky to be not unhappy i have all the
material things i have food warmth love
i have everything so the idea of me
pondering on how i could be happier is
kind of ridiculous
for me the concept of thinking about how
how i could be happier is kind of
i mean really
haven't i got enough i've got everything
i'm so lucky what i'm happy
are you happy yeah whatever yeah
i'm not unhappy
um it's a different thing
there's unhappiness and there's
happiness are you happy is it different
i remember the day i was often happy
i get up on monday and i can't wait to
work to race to work with so many people
i i admire love and trust
um
and i leave home surrounded by people
who i love admire and trust christ what
more could you possibly want than that
i don't know
but it didn't come by accident so i
don't want i'm not i'm not
i'm not just saying luck fell in my lap
that's going to be confusing for anyone
who's watching this i got into the
situation through um
doing a lot and working and acting on
the evidence in other words when things
don't work out it's obvious
change it work harder
if you know
same with your personal relationships
this is all within our domain we can all
do this what advice would you give to me
in my you've you know your career's
banned longer than mine i'm older i'm
much older than you yeah a little bit a
little bit i don't i think you're on the
right track i mean that is why you are
you stand out as being uh this you know
very you've had a huge amount of success
at a very young age so if i was you i
just just stick to what's working
um and your endless pursuit of
transparency and truth
that is what's got you to where you are
today
actually
you're you don't don't underestimate
i don't know how often
anyone in your life
congratulates you or patsy on the back
but i think you must carry on as you are
with showing great empathy
and and warmth so even on i've watched
on dragon's den it's interesting that
you i've noticed you never put anyone
down
you somehow
very human the way you deal with with
everything so your ability to work
within the world of truth is is fabulous
so just don't lose it
don't lose it and don't forget
however much the money is all crap
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest
asks a question to the next guest and
they never know who they're asking it to
so in a nice way all the guests are
talking to each other and they write it
in this book and i don't get to read it
if i if i try and peak jack does
he actually he like shoes me off with
the
hits me with the book okay
i thought about this last night so i can
easily do that you don't know what the
question is
oh god you're going to ask me the
question yes oh lord
but i've thought about myself okay good
okay so let's oh no i wonder who this
was
oh okay
interesting you really don't know what
it is on my mother's life i do not look
and sometimes we have a problem because
the handwriting can be an issue but jack
always checks and i'll see what else
happens jack will tell me if it's a [ __ ]
question so if we had one guy was like
what's your favorite meal deal so jack
told me yeah after this so jack was like
steve the question [ __ ] i was like [ __ ]
but it only happens once in a while
you can keep that in jack mate you
bastard ruining my show
he's my friend so it's okay and he
actually knows he watched the next
episode and was like you didn't ask the
question
are we allowed to know who are who asked
the question you're not allowed to know
okay one day you'll be able to find out
though because we're going to release
them all as of course
so but anyway
the question that's left for you
what is an inadequacy
you admit to that you could work on
starting
tomorrow
no honestly
i mean where do you begin with something
like that
and it's a perfectly good question
but the list is so long so the only way
you can answer a question like that is
is to choose
um the biggest inadequacy and i wouldn't
even know how to do that
i think what i need to do and we all
need to do is embrace all our
inadequacies and and
know what they are and accept them and
and and thrive knowing they're there
that's what we need to do
yeah i'm not going to give you i'm not
going to answer that question by saying
i could i could i could i could kiss my
wife good night you know or
that i'd do that anyway um
or i could go to the gym more i could
get the hundreds of things i'm in a very
inadequate person
what about in your relationships then
because you you reference kissing your
my relationships uh there's so much i
could do better with all my
relationships
i honestly don't know where to start but
at least i'm aware of that what are you
aware of i'm aware of the fact that
to create the way i do to work the way i
do comes at a cost
and the cost is and the cost is i don't
spend enough time
nurturing loving and being supportive
to the people i love most that's just a
fact
do i regret it
no
do i accept it yes do they i pray
and when i'm gone
and if if we continue to build something
remarkable
they'll know that
we're all part of this together this was
made possible by
by them and and myself together with the
team
have you ever had that feedback from
them no uh being as loving no they've
never they've never actually outrightly
criticized me for it but i'm aware of it
i mean i'd have to be
an idiot you know you don't have
children
you're not married you're in a
relationship right
so you you this is all stuff for you to
face in the future i get the feedback
that's why i asked the question yes i
did i find out about most about myself
from my girlfriend turning to me and
saying she should bring me about for
three years or something like that three
isn't enough saying something to me and
me going what are you talking about what
and then walking away and going [ __ ]
she's right
no i i my my all my children misha my
son my eldest son works in the business
and he is
fanatical and brilliant and works really
hard billy my youngest son is a very
talented artist
uh and celeste is is there too so those
three are all they understand exactly
what it's like to be completely
committed and work really really really
hard my fourth step children equally the
youngest ones just got into an
incredible university
uh my eldest one ines they're all very
committed and my wife is just the same
i've never known a person with more
energy more determination who's more
supportive
and generous and loving so
if i've let them all down they've done a
bloody good job of not telling me
when was the last time you cried
oh i cried in movies
all the time
brooke says i cry at all the wrong
things like i cry in movies i cry and
this and this but i don't
she thinks it's weird
she thinks it's really weird to cry
in
you know the voice or something i don't
think it is makes me really moved
what about it makes you move well you
know when you see a young terrified
person come on and perform way beyond
their expectations and do a remarkable
job particularly when they're young and
they have no confidence but they're just
remarkable
just just people who dare
dare take a huge risk don't you think
don't you find it it's so incredible the
way people
dare take a risk it's what we all need
to do so everyone listening and watching
needs to do more
seek transparency take a risk say say it
do it
just just go for it
if some you know and you can do more
than you think and you can say more than
you do so do it
julian thank you it's been welcome
absolutely
fascinating amazing
inspiring conversation your your
personality is just so engaging
and you're thank you i feel like i'm
getting the truth which is which is
really really phenomenal when you as a
speaker especially in the medium of a
podcast the passion you have in
everything you're saying is so
captivating it really really is
captivating and i can imagine i i now i
understand the business and it's funny
that that now having met you and ask you
these questions and sat here with you i
understand
the love and the passion and the
attention to detail and the care for the
people all of those things come through
so much and i also think i know where it
comes from yeah and the the journey
you've had that's led you to really
prioritize treating people well yeah um
and and creating things that are for the
long term so julian thank you
do you want to try something
i invested in the company and i'm on the
board disclaimer and they sponsor the
podcast yeah
they say will come for me if i don't say
that it's hule it's nutritionally
complete
it's got all of the all of the goodness
it's vegan
um
low sugar gluten free
high protein i love the design i love
everything about it i can see why it's
captivating yeah very clear it's very
brilliant this is banana flavor god it's
good it's good isn't it yeah how many
calories do you think this is i i know
how many it is it's roughly 400 i
believe let me check that yeah 400 400
so it's a full meal in a bottle
it's the perfect solution for every
possible control freak in the world
because it's
completely beginning middle and end
that's it exactly wonderfully reassuring
there's no gray area with this
400 calories there it is
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewellery brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery i think i've worn this piece
for almost a year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed color
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly
50 quid i'm not the type of person that
has rolexes or jewelry that cost tens of
thousands of pounds i want pieces that
are reliable that look beautiful and
that holds meaning and significance for
me and that's exactly why i've worn
crafted for so long and when we had the
conversation about them sponsoring this
podcast i was so unbelievably keen for
them to do so check it out if you're a
guy crafted london.com and yeah if you
get any pieces of crafted tag man let me
know what you think
[Music]
you